[Music]
i always told you
that my family wasn't in the war
that's not true what are you talking
about
we were sleeping when some german
soldiers found us
they did horrible things to the women
worse than you can imagine
what's the likelihood that a guy that
attacked you halfway around the world
15 years ago he ends up two blocks away
lewis he's in the trunk
of our car
why are you doing this you don't
remember me your name is carl
i don't know who you're confusing me
with but i'm not in i remember your
whistle your vocals up you're hitting me
i was never in the war you even look the
same to you
yes his eyes i will never forget those
eyes i'm not driving
swiss i have documents to prove it we
need to be certain
i am certain i need to be certain too
victims of trauma sometimes remember the
smallest details perfect
other times they become confused
we have to release it you don't believe
me
what do you want
i want him to confess
we're gonna get caught why are you
taking care of him
he's right you must know something i'm
not the man you think i have no more
lies
we have to put him into this there's
so much that i don't know
[Music]
you